[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
every organization would like their api
program to be successful
quality assurance strategy is about
detecting and correcting problems during
the sdlc
to ensure apis are reliable and
consumers can utilize them to deliver
high quality digital experiences let's
look at the digital value chain again
consider where quality assurance should
be implemented
in most organizations we quickly
identify the technical areas
your backend servers and apis must be
clear of defects
to ensure you are generating great and
quality digital experiences
however focusing solely on protecting
code integrity
is only the start of a quality assurance
strategy your team should actively
participate
and have a culture of continuous quality
assurance as well
developers and key team members must
consistently strive
to find prevent and correct issues
quality assurance should also be an
active process in deploying
your connected experiences this can be
automated through a continuous
integration
and delivery tools that can also help
with unit testing
integration testing and performance
testing the principle of automation
and quality is an essential part of
digital transformation
cicd often helps reduce rework and
technical debt
while maintaining quality throughout the
entire development life cycle
some of the benefits of ci cd with the
help of automation
include increasing the speed of fining
fixing
code and integration errors decreasing
the cost of finding and fixing those
errors
increasing dev team's confidence and
code stability
increasing dev team's frequency and
releasing the code to production
but successful quality assurance
strategies must also occur
at the customer level leveraging your
customers to receive feedback
test new features and services and
validate user experiences
must be an integral part of your
continuous improvement process
and ensure that your organization is
able to keep your customers happy
let's take a look at the details within
quality assurance
here are a few factors to consider when
building your quality assurance strategy
reducing risks is critical in your qa
strategy
the risk of a bad experience reaching
the customer can be greatly reduced
when regression testing and continuous
quality assurance is in place
be sure that your team understands what
the objectives
requirements and acceptance criteria are
for new features and changes to your
apis
the key is to make sure your
requirements are clearly aligned with
your business needs
and stakeholders expectations does your
team
have the right technical skills and
capacity to ensure quality assurance is
being met
as testing becomes increasingly
automated qa engineers are replacing
manual testing efforts your api team and
testers
should automation testing and qa skills
as well as understanding of the key test
frameworks in the development cycle
understand how your products work and
how the tools can be used to help
maintain your quality assurance
each tool in your ci cd process along
with your api platform can be leveraged
in your qa strategies the business must
support a culture of quality assurance
and continuous improvement as well
this means including qa further upstream
in the requirements
and design process and also
collaboration between the product owner
qa
to mutually define acceptance criteria
in test cases
finally also consider any organizational
regulations that are required
these may also drive quality and may
require specific standards to satisfy
feature release
having your regulations understood by
everyone on your team
will prevent needless cycles to approve
new features
so let's summarize everything with a few
key strategies
to build quality into your sdlc
the first is to make time to test
unfortunately some teams often looked at
qa as an afterthought
only when something breaks does the
questions come up or is our quality
assurance
have dedicated time and qa role embedded
in your daily routine to test your apis
and validate quality
second everyone is responsible for
quality as we discussed earlier
everyone is responsible throughout your
digital value chain and software
development lifecycle
to test detect prevent and correct
issues
do not hand off qa to someone else
follow through
on every issue third documentation
is essential the more your team gets
comfortable with documenting product
features
and product issues the better your
quality will get
this should happen to every layer of
your experiences back end
front end and apis we discuss gherkin as
a great way to document both a
requirement and a test scenario at one
time
this smart way of writing saves a ton of
team time
and helps enable everyone to weigh in
furthermore
gerkin can be converted directly into
programmatic test scripts
saving even more time fourth
automate testing but don't avoid manual
testing
we discussed on your ci cd pipeline can
assist in quality assurance processes
by standardized testing deployment and
integration
but don't solely rely on automated
testing
your team should always get involved and
conduct manual tests
to validate the automated testing is
working properly
fifth test early and often
quality is about consistently delivering
quality experiences
your code designs apis and user
experiences
should constantly be reviewed and
supported to ensure continuous quality
insurance
testing in each sprint right off the
coast is developed is a great way to
catch bugs
before they are a larger impact
oftentimes the qa
and the developer will sit side by side
together at the end of the sprint to do
a qa walk through
something's found the developer will fix
it on the spot
and no defect ticket even needs to be
logged
finally and sixth include your customers
in the process
your customers are in developer
community can help ensure quality
invite them to a user testing at the end
of the sprint or have them play with an
alpha or beta version of your apis
building
a pilot customer group can be one of
your most
valuable assets listen to what they have
to say
and issues they report to you everyone
should be involved
with equality assurance hopefully you've
found a few strategies in the
presentation
to help build a successful quality
assurance strategy to support your apis
any ongoing development and customer
experiences
if you want more information check out
the community
for ebooks articles and other related
topics
thank you for watching